[Music]
[Applause]
uh Buster Olney the great reporter and
Senior writer for the mothership Sunday
Night Baseball Sunday night baseball
Astros Angels coverage starts at 7
Eastern on the mother shed let me let me
start there with show hey Tony it feels
like it's the only story in baseball how
big is the coverage going to get with
shohei uttani over the next two weeks
buster
uh it is going to dominate the sport uh
where the question is going to be asked
every day you know have you heard
anything about the Angels putting the
word out that they're ready to talk
about ohtani
um you know Artie Moreno in the end in
this decision it's not going to be Perry
manassie in the general manager you know
this I mean it's going to be the owner
Artie Moreno who said in spring training
that he was not going to trade Otani as
long as they were contending well we're
going into this two-week period where
they're Chase they're going to be facing
teams that they're chasing they start
out with the Astros then they play the
Yankees and a few series later they play
the Toronto Blue Jays and then they face
the Atlanta Braves before the the trade
deadline and at some point in those last
72 to 96 hours we should hear we
probably uh might hear from Artie Moreno
about whether or not he's going to trade
ohtani and if he is traded you talk
about a frenzy you know idiots like me
are going to be talking about this 24
hours a day let's look at the
possibilities here because we we do I
know there's a lot of speculation
there's probably wishful reporting for
people in the media but if you were
saying how many viable candidates could
trade for shohei Otani
not as many as people think right uh a
he's making 30 million dollars this
season which means that to take him on
for the last two months you're taking on
10 million dollars and you're giving up
a boatload of prospects you know young
Major League ready players and they're
just not a lot of teams who necessarily
would entertain that for example if the
Dodgers have made some of the biggest
moves at the trade deadline over the
last six seven years Manny Machado for
example what I'm hearing from general
managers is they don't know if the
Dodgers this year would do that type of
move
um I think the Yankees absolutely would
be all in which makes sense to me
because you've got Aaron judge and
Garrett Cole and Giancarlo Stan
essentially being middle-aged in their
Major League careers this is their
opportunity to win the Texas Rangers are
competitively relevant for the first
time in a decade veritin that might be
in and maybe a wild card would be the
Tampa Bay race you know their front
office is not typically a team that
would spend the kind of money and re
Source package but on the other hand
they had such a great first half before
hemorrhaging ground toward the the back
end leading the All-Star break and maybe
they would be uh uniquely aggressive
well like uh when uh Freddie Freeman was
a free agent they finished second in
that bidding behind the Dodgers so I
think those are three teams to watch it
might be one or two others but not
nearly as many as what people think I
thought the Giants just because of the
location they were all in on Judge and
Carlos Correa could the Giants be a wild
card in this
yes but I would say again this scouting
reports provided by uh general managers
around the sport Farhan zaidi runs their
baseball operations Department this is
not the type of move that he would
typically make where again the
combinations of dollars which they have
a ton of they didn't sign judge they
didn't sign Correa uh and the prospects
that's going to be required and you know
I think Farhan in a clear-eyed moment
you know he'd probably ask himself the
question are we close to being a
championship caliber team and I think
the honest answer at this moment would
be no
have the Angels made an offer
I I don't know if they've actually put a
number out there because as you know you
know the way this works is they
essentially approach the agent and ask
the question are you ready to hear a
number are you ready to negotiate and
they get fended off Scott Boris has made
a career of doing this uh and I suspect
that a similar conversation has taken
place between the angels and otani's
agent nesboleo uh sometime in the next
six in the last six months I asked this
question in the last 48 hours hey any
sign of any last negotiation where the
Angels go to Otani and say look uh we're
ready to put a big number in front of
you are you ready to hear that and the
answer I got back was no which makes
sense I mean he's this close to free
agency of walking into this perfect
storm of of desperate big Market bidders
Dodgers Mets you know Giants you
mentioned Mariners maybe the Padres
maybe the Yankees why not play it out
when you're this close to free agency
all right I'm gonna make Moreno
what do you do
well and and if I'm already Moreno not
sleeping because on one hand it's pretty
clear that the best baseball move is to
trade him to get the prospects back uh
but on the other hand why do we know the
name Harry Frazee only for one reason he
was the guy who delivered the singular
Talent out of Boston into the hands of
the New York Yankees if you're already
Moreno politically with your fan base
and maybe for your legacy the easiest
thing to do is to wait till the fall
give an offer to ohtani if he turns it
down and that's what people expect that
he's going to do then you're off the
hook if you deliver him out of town for
prospects that's going to be your legacy
forever it's why last summer I think
when the front office the Angels did its
due diligence they talked to other teams
they collected information took it to
Artie from what I understand already
went crazy like he was Furious that they
entertained the idea of trading ohtani
in my gun is that's where he lands in
the end especially I mean otani's having
the greatest season we've ever seen he's
on a pace that 56 homers driving 125
runs strike out 235 guys and you're
going to trade that guy in the middle of
that season for Artie I think it's a lot
more complicated than hey what's the
prospect package we get we're talking to
Buster only ESPN Sunday Night Baseball
reporters senior writer coming up Sunday
night it'll be the Astros and the angels
how long have you been at ESPN
uh 20 years just uh past my anniversary
uh just in June and you were a baseball
reporter baseball writer and then you
made the transition how difficult was
the transition to go from print to being
on TV extremely difficult and I get
asked the question all the time when I
speak in front of Journalism uh students
and your name always comes up because
they tell the story about the first time
I did a a hit on SportsCenter with you
it's the first time I'd ever met you and
of course I had a lot of nervousness my
heart rate was like 200 I get makeup for
the first time to go in studio and I
walk in and the stage manager put me in
front of a camera what's known as a
single shot and I I was relieved because
I had done that before some familiar
ground for me and then the show goes to
commercial 67 pockets and all of a
sudden five cameras and you come moving
toward me you've got your great TV voice
your comfort level that I'll never have
uh and you're like hey Buster how's it
going and all I'm thinking about is oh
my God where am I supposed to look and
you were very funny because you're kind
of Chatty and you're also like it's very
easy you look at the jib and then you
come back to me and then you look at
camera one you give your answer then you
come back to me and then you look back
at the seconds and I'm on air and you
ask me a question about Javi Lopez
signing with the Orioles and I forgot
everything I forgot who he was I forgot
what city he was gonna play for like I
forgot what position he was going to
play uh you know you've seen Broadcast
News the Flop Set uh you know scene that
was me with about 30 more seconds thank
God they got me off air in time and you
ushered me out of the studio I'm sure
and I was met by Chuck so eturo was his
you know great editor for ESPN for so
many years he met me and he said ah
don't worry about it you know you'll uh
you'll figure it out we got you for your
information and so in that time I've
been able to reduce my heart rate from
like 280. it was in that moment to now
probably about 110. yeah you know it's
tough being a talking hairdo buster
oh man if you had to make a World Series
pick today who would it be
um you know I know I say the most
dangerous team in baseball right now
would be the Philadelphia Phillies which
is really odd because you know the
Braves have been playing out of their
minds they've actually gained games in
the standings over the last uh over the
Phillies the last month but since June
3rd the Phillies are 23-9 they have a
296 era their pitching Has Come Together
dramatically they have an era uh more
than half a run better than any other
team and you know Dave Dombrowski had a
baseball Ops if they have holes before
the deadline they're going to fill them
they haven't seen the best at a Trey
Turner Bryce Harper hasn't hit for power
yet he will eventually that's why I
think the Braves uh the head of baseball
Ops Alex and topless he needs to fix
that pitching staff and plug holes
they're okay they haven't gotten Max
freed back yet but at some point when
they do he's got to identify pitching
because I think the Phillies are a
really dangerous team in the postseason
with the front of their rotation what
about the American League
boy I I would have told you a month ago
um that it would be the Tampa Bay Rays
I'm kind of conflicted now I do feel
like that if the Yankees make a big move
uh as much as they're struggling now if
they get judged back this is their best
postseason pitching staff that I think
they may have put together in the last
five or six years because that Bullpen
is totally dominant rodon is back you
got Garrett Cole let's play it out let's
say they do give up the players to get
ohtani that would be the team to beat in
the American Lake
but is there added pressure on Judge
then to come back
yeah I think there is but I also believe
that the way the Yankees uh culturally
with their players they always play the
long game you know teams will often try
to rush players back from injuries the
Yankees always consider to be October
part of their season so I think they're
going to slow play it they'll follow his
body because let's face it given the the
calendar if he has one setback Dan
that's it he's done for the year
Buster great to talk to you as always
thanks for joining us
thanks Dan always fun to talk with you
Buster only ESPN Sunday night baseball
and he's part of the festivities this
Sunday night it'll be the Astros and the
angels